hello everybody
it's good to be here in the land of the
free
we are just popping off right now
talking about the submersible
a topic that we all have talked about
before
um something about the submersible that
you might not know
is that it was very sad that it happened
so here's the thing like when you have
an Uber
you should be like hey how much are you
getting out of this
because I'm paying thirty dollars and
I'll be like Oh I'm only getting like
twenty dollars like hey the cancellation
fee is twenty is five dollars why don't
I just give you
uh
uh why don't I just give you 22 dollars
[__] what was it so the cancellation
fees five dollars they're getting 20.
just take the cancellation fee that's
five give them 20. that's 25 and then
you cut out the middle man you can even
throw them four bucks extra save a
dollar just to cut out Uber out of the
whole thing but then Uber's probably
gonna get mad and if you have tuna
cancellations they're gonna know what's
up
but on the short term
this is something that we should all do
because they're basically just a [__]
um
like uh get together just put your
people together it's just like hey you
meet this person here and that shouldn't
be taking like 25 of the profits that's
just doesn't even seem like
it's that hard to do
um but I guess they have the market
share
and all that
I heard they're going to make a movie
about the submersible directed by James
Cameron it's going to be called Titan
and the nude scenes are going to be
between the Pakistani dad and his son
so they're gonna be [__] each other
it's gonna be a short film because
not a lot happened on that trip
it's going to be mostly on the boat
before they get there that's where all
the [__] happens
if my head is upright for too long then
my neck starts hurting
so
yeah let's take uh
let's take a minute to
um
thank the people that are doing deep sea
diving and submersibles so that we could
enjoy
watching the news stories about when
they die
I bet the amount of publicity that this
new story got is worth like a thousand
submersible trips
it's like hey you paid for yourself you
can't kept us entertained between June
uh 19 and
June 27th that kind of entertainment is
hard to get man that's it's valuable
people being entertained that keeps them
working for longer and all that
keeps them more motivated gives them
office cooler talk so that they can
continue to be cubicle jockeys
and um
so they can uh have something to talk
about and they'll work a little harder
um but yeah
South Korea was amazing thank you for
asking
South Korea was like
a country where
like people that are like Hey we're
gonna try to get along with each other
and we don't really hate each other that
much we're all the same ethnically it's
like with the ethnic things all whatever
it's like who we don't have to think
about ethnics or ethnicity anymore we
can just get to the business of
governing and having a great society
and it's like yeah let's just try to
help each other and create the most
efficient system of Transportation
instead of just having like
um
uh part of your country that you're like
[__] this part
this part is gross I hate this part this
part is for the poor people we're gonna
skip around all of that
and get to the good parts
so that all the white parts of the
country are connected and you can pass
over all the black Parts like it's so
crazy that America is a country where
that's like
that's like actively torturing parts of
itself so that
they can continue to live off of them
they're like we can give you more but
that's not really what this is about
it's about us and we're going to give
you less even though we could give you
more just because we don't want you to
get too comfortable
artificial scarcity
are you married how old are you I'm not
married
I think marriage is great
um if you get divorced but I don't
really think people were meant to be
with the same person that they were with
when they were 18. whenever I see
someone who's been married to the same
person since they were 18 they just feel
like they're in a
bubble like they're in there's like a
film between me and them it's like hello
can you hear me they're like yes yes I'm
living a fantastic life
it's like are you though that's
plastered On Smile they're just like ah
everything's fine and happy it's like
this isn't realistic you just have to
tell yourself that your life is perfect
because if it wasn't then
you've been missing out on a lot and you
have a lot more work to do to catch up
but yeah I think like being married to
the same person since you were young is
sort of like
you didn't get to live your life
um
yeah it's just sort of like
so much of the world was cut off from
you your primary USB port was occupied
by another slot
you couldn't stick it into other USBS
and download the information from their
vaginas
you're still using floppy disks
you got the old way of connecting and
now people are connecting to each other
and downloading information off each
other with their buttholes
so yeah that's kind of a conflict of
interest like yeah
one of my interests is keeping my wife
happy that I had kids with them out of
panic
and then the other interest is having a
great time and getting to know people
and learning from their genitals I
learned a lot from people's genitals
and if someone paid you ticket would you
have gone to see the Titanic
yeah
um maybe not in person
but like
maybe just a camera that they Dangle on
a rope
is being so much too much optimistic
harmful if yes how improve
very Eastern European way to phrase that
question if yes how improve
if it's being too much optimistic kind
of food
we all run the same 1.6 gigahertz radio
wave so being optimistic is to
uh is harmful
because then you'll be like ah what a
wonderful Society we live in let me just
relax and not do anything about it
and then you have to justify the
horrible things that go on in society
you're like this is a great society
and the black person that just got
murdered that's also a part of it
because that's important because he
deserved it and if people deserve it you
should be able to murder them and then
you have to justify all the horrible
things that are going on in the world
that you have to have be optimistic it's
just so limiting to be like I have to be
happy no matter what happens my
happiness is going to be Paramount
then you're like sacrificing logic and
reality just to make yourself happy
and it's like so [__] up because then
you can't observe reality you're like oh
that's kind of ugly and gross I'm not
gonna download that information because
I need to be happy and that makes me sad
so then it's like you can only search
you can only parse certain information
only things that make you feel good and
you can't
you know
you can't download things that are going
to make you sad it's like if you can be
sad then you can download so much more
information and maybe things that
initially seem sad can have like some
happiness to it but just like going off
your emotions and trying to be
optimistic all the time is kind of
it's like you're it's so needy that your
ability to uh you know
take in reality and understand reality
is impaired by your need to be happy so
yeah you shouldn't be too happy but he
also shouldn't be
too sad and depressed because
if you're too sad and depressed
then you're like oh I get happiness from
being sad and if something is sad that
means I was correct about everything and
all the people that were happy were
incorrect so everything I see needs to
be sad because that'll make me happy
everything is about happiness at the end
of the day and if you're trying to be
too happy then you're a bad person
because you should be able to be sad
you shouldn't just have to be happy all
the time because sometimes your
happiness gets in the way of other
people's happiness
and uh if it's all about happiness then
what is it really about well I just
think like uh happiness shouldn't be the
end goal it should be a byproduct of
doing other things and if you're just
pursuing happiness you're just pursuing
uh the dopamine rush and the drug
instead of actually what the happiness
is supposed to be for which is a
signifier of other things
both of the top 10 players in the NBA is
worth more than dozens of countries now
that's truly wealth disparity and racism
is not the issue
so I mean you can have a country where
you pay 10 players in the NBA a lot of
money who happen to be black and also
have horrible wealth inequality and
racism
just because there are 10 black people
making lots of money doesn't mean racism
doesn't exist
is being too much up to uh
be more realistic
someone said nice glass is very Korean
thank you
yeah I got pretty Korean glasses
are you guys hearing that I think
there's a party going on in my house
which is crazy
I really wish
that wasn't happening
I want to be the only thing being
vibrant in my house I don't want there
to be
conflict and fight fightings
between
my energies
and also I have my girlfriend coming
over and it's going to be hard to be
[__] if there's a lot of people just
talking and chit chatting
but what about a meta okayness this
means that despite being happier and
happy there is a context of being okay
with whatever comes
yeah I think you should definitely try
to be okay with things that come and you
should be happy in Who You Are
but you shouldn't like have weaponized
happiness or you're like I'm happier
than you so I must be a better person
and everyone should listen to me because
I am good at being happy for no reason
it's like being happy for no reason
should just be a given if it comes that
easily to you you shouldn't need to
proselytize and tell everyone about how
to be happy for no reason like you
that's like okay that's like a base
level thing it's like making your bed
it's like yeah you should make your bed
but it shouldn't be your whole
personality it's not a very deep thing
to help people with just because you
make your bed isn't going to fix wealth
inequality or racism
uh the closet is back there I think it's
just cheap wood what is your biggest
problem in the universe
probably black holes if you think people
are evil
imagine the destruction caused by a
black hole
to planets and whatever
uh you ever been with a squirter I've
been with a girl who we had sex and she
peed on me slash squirted that it's cool
even if it is p
I I closed the closet doors behind me
because it looks messy if I don't I sort
of made my bed very haphazardly
there's the dummy the Jiu Jitsu dummy
that's perfectly situated behind my head
um
so will Griffin asks longest road or
largest army I would have to go with
longest road because it's visually
impressive largest army is so fragile I
mean it's hard to knock someone off
largest army this is Katan uh and
Catania get points for having the
longest road or the largest army they're
like wow impressive here's two points
for doing that it's like so Random what
they give out points for but it all
comes together and it works it's a
beautiful game
largest army it's like you can move the
robber once and get someone's resource
but with roads you can cut people off
and get to where you want to go and you
can see it and it can [__] up other
people's games the rubber is useful you
can [__] up people's games with it but
also there's so many sevens ruled that
your robber is going to be minimized in
certain games
but yeah I like playing development
cards because it's
trickier it's sneakier it's not as
obvious of a way to play and it's it
shocks newbies
but other than that it's like just
another style of playing
um some scientists say that turguska
tunguska event was a tiny black hole
that hit the earth at the speed of light
and it's the exit point
exit Point like a butthole like the
universe's butthole
my own Rumble with Tim Dylan and Danny
paulshuk
Rumble is that like a right-wing
independent social media Network because
I'm not on Rumble
is bad Zoomer trying to get me on Rumble
I am not really right-wing but you know
if you guys are okay with me shouting
communist propaganda I'll join any
network I kind of need a structure
because without structure I don't really
I don't really get off my ass it's hard
for me to do things
without structure so that's what a good
thing about a company is because I'm
like I'm all natural I'm an organic
podcaster I only podcast when I
organically feel like it and then I
never do it because I never feel like
doing it
even though I have a podcast studio in
my room and in my house it's just like
I don't know I never get around to it
so it that's what I need corporations
for I need a like a daddy Corporation
just to be like do your homework now and
be like okay fine I grew up with the
structure of school and church and now
it's ingrained into my brain and I need
I need a larger Corporation to give me
something to do
it's so sad I need to be able to produce
this endogenously endogenous motivation
that's a must for protection ows in my
humble opinion ows is that cities and
nights or I don't know what ows is I
don't I need to figure out how to play
cities and nights I've been playing so
much of the Standard Version I don't
even know how to play cities and nights
it's so embarrassing
if my friend is going through a rough
patch what can I say to comfort her
because everything's gonna be okay is BS
it depends on what the rough patch is
you got to make it specific and uh hyper
hyper-specific and individualized to her
experience because you know sometimes
she might not be okay and that's
comforting to hear someone say that or
to know that
um
but yeah I mean a rough patch I mean she
can't get a dick why can't she get dick
I feel like it must be pretty easy for a
woman get to get dick I mean
I think
I think really what the big deal is with
um
the [__]
rough patch whatever that means is like
you feel isolated from everyone else for
whatever reason like your mom died or
you're not getting any dick and the
people that can comfort you are not the
people that you want to be comforted by
the people that they want to be
comforted by
are strangers with big tits or
uh people that will have sex with them
and cure their existential existential
dread by tugging on their genitals
um so if you're in a position to comfort
someone is going through a rough patch
you're probably not the person they want
to be comforted by otherwise they
wouldn't be going through that rough
patch they probably don't respect you in
some way
because if they'd respected you and they
had you in
they had you in their life they wouldn't
be so sad and in a rough patch so you
should take it personally and be like oh
this person isn't satisfied in life
knowing me they're sad even though they
know me and I'm a part of their life so
you should be like taking it taking it
personally if some if your friends are
sad that means they don't respect you
because
your your presence alone should be
enough to make them feel good
I mean if she's going through other
issues like health care or you know job
loss like that's a governmental thing
and I'm sorry that we don't have good
social safety nets but yeah I feel like
if you want to help your friend through
her rough patch maybe vote for
socialists and create a society that
helps people
and uh that'll help her because she's a
person and people are the ones that go
through rough patches a lot of the time
if my friend is going through a rough
passion keeps saying she wants that how
can I comfort her because everything is
okay it's gonna it's BS I feel like you
already said that are you just copy
pasting
I am sure why image would be a daddy
Corp and you can do add to add you to
their ever expanding podcast lineup who
is it
hi